what a prick any man over 40 on the
Instagram is weird and that weirdo is
performance artist Yann Hakan Eriksson
he has over 500 of these artsy balloons
snuff films real long winters in
Norway's my guests time well spent
balloons aren't his only medium he also
dabbles in dry pasta but mainly balloons
I see his work as a metaphor about how
all arts programs should be defunded
immediately as a tribute to Yann I
decided to pop the most erotic balloons
of them all
[Laughter]
this is obviously an art piece about how
sex has become too safe in the workplace
everyone knows that the most exciting
thing about intercourse is spending the
next three months terrified that
someone's pregnant
you